[Musique]
je suis au festival de cannes pour y
présenter dans le cadre du chantier mme
korner un court métrage de fiction que
j'ai réalisé et convient donc ici
présenté au marché pour trouver des
débouchés supplémentaires pour le faire
ce film raconte l'histoire de jules qui
est un jeune papa divorcé qui est sur le
point de refaire sa vie dans un
environnement extrêmement différent de
celui qui est son environnement
d'origine et qui se pose beaucoup de
questions au moment de faire part de ses
nouveaux choix à son fils dont il part
du principe qu'il ne va pas pouvoir
comprendre ses choix et donc il essaie
de mettre en place des stratégies pour
croit-il faciliter les choses et c'est
pas forcément comme ça que ça va se
passer
la gare est aussi reparti au lit ça va
tourner sur youtube le virent c'est bon
comme ça tu es chéri
je t'emmène au far west c'est quoi mon
parcours à moi m'a amené dans la jeune
adolescente arrivée en région parisienne
d'une région qui était beaucoup plus
isolé que ça au départ et donc ça a été
pour moi l'apprentissage de la
différence culturelle ça y est t'es dans
les yvelines à saint quentin en yvelines
c'était très neuf pour moi de découvrir
tout ce brassage culturel
du coup c'est quelque chose qui m'a
insultes beaucoup accompagnés et quand
j'ai commencé à faire des films
immédiatement j'ai réintégré sa dans les
problématiques de mes films et notamment
la migration est devenu quelque chose
qui m'a beaucoup beaucoup préoccuper
quelqu'un te présenter
[Musique]
du coup dans ce film là il s'agit pas
que d'un parcours migratoire parce que
c'est aussi des choix de vie ça pourrait
tout à fait être un personnage blanc qui
déciderait d'aller vers ce milieu
western qui est un petit peu particulier
mais évidemment ça m'intéressait
d'autant plus de rajouter la
problématique migratoire encore une fois
est alléchante de l'ouest jeux contes et
légendes du blues